so you go from doing that um when what
cuz cuz you I mean is it safe to say
you've tried every pretty like the only
I'd say major drugs or like main drugs I
haven't
tried wasn't really popular in my area
when I was young but now it is I haven't
really done either no no no
wow Haven done I did smoke one time how
okay I got to know this cuz I always I
watch um snowfall have you watched the
show snowfall no so it's I've heard of
it though great show right in this show
everyone who
smokes they they end up sucking for it
and I guess the like you know the stigma
about is that it's so good that straight
men will suck to get more of it if
they're poor y so how was smoking
honestly pretty I'm not going to lie and
granted I might have had a bit of a
skewed experience cuz we made this and
none of us knew how to do it so you
recked your own yeah yeah we went on we
were so we gotten out of school and I
had a buddy named Ashton and he used to
sell a bunch of he show up to school and
just like serve kids you know gra bags
in the bathroom and Sh one day we get
out of school and he's got a baggie on
him and we get a ride over to my place
and we were originally just going to
like chill out do some bumps and he's
like yo I'm bored of this let's you step
it up like let's cook this yeah let's do
some so we hop on our phones and we
start looking up we were literally just
on like YouTube and just like how to
cook yeah and we're on Google looking
this up and there's a bunch of these
little forums that you can go on that
are just in the dep the pits of the
internet like you shouldn't be on and um
we're finding these like stepbystep
guides and we found this one where this
guy had a video and it was how to make
like a personal serving in a spoon and
we were like yo all you need is baking
soda you know a little water lighter in
a spoon and some tin foil and a goddamn
freezer and you're in this [__] and we
had all those things so we were like yo
let's try it so we went through the
process you know we took one of my mom's
little spoons and we we cooked up on
there and then we we transferred it onto
the tin foil after we' separated
everything we froze it and we let it sit
for like felt like an eternity probably
like 5 minutes you know we were
impatient um and then we pulled it out
and we realized we were like damn we got
nothing to smoke it out of so then we
had to make a little tin foil pipe and
smoke it out of that um honestly it was
kind of like underwhelming and it was
probably just cuz we cook some garbage
like a the cocaine couldn't have been
great we were like 16 you know and B we
didn't know what the we were doing you
know so so you you didn't you probably
didn't have the uh the full like the
full experience with crack but I did
feel it and I it was it lasted like 2
minutes if even and it was
like have you ever done Coke I've never
done any drugs but hallucinogenics and
weed okay that's good that's good for
the viewers out there that's good um I
grew up in a house where my aunt and my
uncle's all their spoons were burnt they
were I had a bunch of dope fiend in my
yes you didn't want to be around that
you don't want to do that yeah okay uh
for me it was the opposite all my spoons
were clean so I
was yeah um so I um oh God I lost my
train ofone no we were talking about uh
you asked me I'd ever done Coke yeah
yeah so
um essentially like when you when you do
Coke it's like every time you do the
first line from being like bone sober
you just get this like this rush it goes
straight to your head and you feel it
and then it kind of like comes down over
you got to keep doing more right with
crack it's like that rush like you know
how when I said with the coke it kind of
comes down over you with crack it never
comes down over you it just straight
rush and you're it's like Coke sped up
you know you're just on like 100 times
speed everything goes by very quickly I
got pissed off I remember I punched my
mom's cabinet I was like yo like I so my
friend hit it and then he passed it to
me and he was like yo like this is this
is crazy and I hit it and I was like
yeah and I just sent it through the
cabinet you know I was like yeah dude
this is awesome so you you hit the crack
and then punch your mom's cabinet almost
immediately yeah pretty much immediately
and I was just like me and my friend
were just body boxing each other we were
just punching each other cracking around
yeah just passing the little tin foil
pipe around um and it lasted a whole
like 120 seconds if even we came down
and we were just like oh that was kind
of underwhelming you know damn it's gone
already yeah I was expecting a little
better out of that but I also totally
get why crackheads exist you get it cuz
like yeah cuz even that God awful like
garbage crack we cooked I still felt
like you know a little little hey now
you know a little lit um I could only
imagine what the Good's like yeah cuz
you always hear like everybody who does
crack they're just they just spend the
rest of their life chasing the first
time they did it yeah which is a very um
that sounds amazing to me which is I
don't
want yeah you know that's that's I think
you know I'm very thankful that my first
experience with with was with crack this
is true cuz you cuz you not you might
not be here right now oh yeah if it was
good crack I would have been out there
dude I would have been gone